ahora mismo con poco más del 80%
escrutado tenemos a un resetta
hiperdogan con un 50,6% aproximadamente
de los votos cada vez acercándose más al
límite ese del 50% bajando por lo tanto
con cada voto que se contabiliza receta
y perdón va restando menos a esa ventaja
que con respecto a qué mal líder
opositor por lo que cada vez podemos
decir que estamos más cerca de que se
vaya a producir una segunda vuelta en
estas elecciones en Turquía que se
producirían a finales de mayo alberti
precisamente de Cara a esta posible
segunda vuelta Qué sería de los votos de
simán o gane el tercer candidato que sin
embargo por el momento suma acerca del
5% de los apoyos muy lejos de este 50 y
40 por ciento Que de momento acumulan
tanto erdogan como
es la gran pregunta que se hace ahora
mismo toda Turquía que será de los votos
para sin anuar el mismo candidato
presidencial o han ya ha dicho que aún
no se ha decantado por ninguno de los
dos candidatos Y esto es un hecho
bastante importante aquí en Turquía
puesto que normalmente los electores que
votan a un candidato En caso de que este
candidato no pase a una segunda ronda le
harían casos y él pide el voto para
hiperdogán o para
quemarrolus sí que es verdad que sinan o
han ya hecho una serie de declaraciones
buenas declaraciones hacia el ministro
del interior Suleiman soy Lu ahora mismo
Poner doggán por lo tanto algunos pueden
ver en estas palabras
un digamos una forma de decir que pedirá
el voto para
aún así aún no se ha pronunciado la
delegación de Voto aquí en Turquía puede
llegar a ser una cosa bastante común la
pudimos ver ya hace unos años con el
partido procurdo cuando pidió el voto
para el candidato opositor gremy en las
elecciones aquí locales en Estambul
también lo hicieron para las elecciones
locales en ankara y lo hicieron en estas
mismas elecciones para el candidato
opositor que marketilizaron por lo tanto
lo que diga o han de hacer sobre A quién
votar si a erdogan o que mal que licharo
Lulu será sumamente importante para ver
esta diferencia y al verte estas
elecciones han sido descritas como las
más reñidas en años como unas elecciones
cruciales tanto para el país como para
la región le preguntó Cuál es el
ambiente en los lugares donde digamos
haya multitudes o grupos de personas que
están siguiendo este escrutinio
sí Según veíamos en las redes sociales
ya muchos seguidores de recetas y perdón
se han empezado a volcar en ankara a las
puertas de la Sede del partido esperando
unos resultados que por ahora no son
nada claros a nivel de calle sigue la
tranquilidad todo el mundo todo el país
está pendiente de lo que salgan los
resultados de estas elecciones por lo
tanto todo el mundo está ahora mismo en
sus casas mirando las pantallas para ver
cómo se produce este escrutinio y para
ver si realmente vamos a ir a una
segunda vuelta o por el contrario
seguirá imponiéndose